- René Richard Cyr, on se
retrouve sur la scène du Théâtre
du Nouveau Monde, où vous allez
présenter à nouveau "Les trois
soeurs" de Tchekhov, arrêtée à
cause de la COVID il y a 2 ans.
- Oui.
- Allez, osssssse
par la cuisine.
- Les arts de la scène,
c'est toute votre vie.
Comment vous avez vécu les deux
dernières années avec
ouvertures, fermetures?
RENÉ RICHARD CYR, metteur en
scène, réalisateur et comédien
- C'est un yoyaiaiais nous
sommes... On est tous suspendus
à la même corde de yoyo,
on est tous...  Alors donc,
j'avais de la difficulté
à lever le poing ou à dire :
Oui, mais moi, oui mais nous...
Ce que je trouve le plus dur,
c'est pour les jeunes.
T'sais, j'ennananais à l'École
nationale l'année dernière.
Là, les s,s,s,s, les...
Puis en même temps, eux,
ils sortent de l'école.
Tout l'avenir leur appartient,
puis là, c'est comme si!!!!
Je trouvais ça plus difficile
pour eux que pour nous.
Mais ce n'est pas le concours
de qui est-ce qui fait le plus
pitié non plus, là, t'sais,
tu comprends-tu?
- Vous avez mis en scène
75 pièces de théâtre, entre
autres.
- Ah oui?
- Entre autres.
- OK...
- "Caligula", "L'homme de
la Mancha", les "Belles-soeurs :
théâtre musical".
Votre homologue Serge rtrtrtrtrt
m'a dit : "On passe toujours
à quelques instants de
la catastrophe à la veille
d'un spectacle."
- Oui.
- C'est vrai, ça?
- Bien oui, c'est vrai!
Parce que c'est éminemment
fragile. C'est un art fragile,
c'est un art de communication.
T'sais, on appelle ça
le quatrième mur, là, ici,
mais il n'y a pas véritablement
de mur, c'est-à-dire qu'on est
en contact avec les gens.
Allez-vous par là, les deux!
Mettez-vous pas... ça ouvre!
Moi, les jeudis, vendredis
soirs, il m'est déjà arrivé
des moments épiques de dire :
ngngngngnge tout! On enlève les
chapeaux, on enlève les robes,
on change... on enlève les
prendrions, on met l'orchestre
ailleurs
Parce que je me dis : C'est
pas  ça que je veux faire, là,
tout à coup. T'sais, je me plais
toujours à dire : mimimimimimise
en scène, c'est faire
un casse-tête, mais t'as pas
le dessus de la boîte.
Pour dîner... Viens!
- Dans votre excellente
biographie rencontre
"René Richard Cyr :
l'entremetteur en scène"...
- Avec André Ducharme, à
l'invitation d'André Ducharme.
- Vous écrivez que vous êtes
le meilleur maniaque sur Terre.
Ça veut dire quoi et en quoi
ça vous aide dans votre métier
d'être maniaque?
- Bien, maniaque... C'est-à-dire
que quand je prends une oeuvre,
ça devient mon livre de chevet.
Je lis, je relis, je relis
et j'annote. C'est là que
je dis que je viens maniaque.
C'est-à-dire que je devienspréc,
à la limite du téteux...
Non, mais ça commence
à sentir le coup de...
- Là, ça commence à sentir
le coup de poing sur la gueule.!
Parce que j'ai une petite
tendance à être compulsif,
à faire       à mettre
tout par ordre alphabétique,
à mettre mes assiettes que je
lave en dessous pour qu'il y ait
un bon roulement d'a
T'sais, dans le sens, je suis
un petit peu maniaque sur mes
affaires, mais en même temps,
je pense que je suis de nature
agréable. Je ne suis pas
du tout...
(rires)
Non, mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que je ne suis pas
un metteur en scène qui...
t'sais, il y en a qui disent :
"Il faut briser les gens.
Je vais t'amener dans
tes derniers retranchements."
Moi, je ne veux pas rentrer
dans ton jardin secret avecmes .
C'est correct, là.
- J'aime beaucoup René Richard
Cyr le comédien, et je vais
lalalalalalalalaisir. Je veux pr
du rôle du caïd dans
"C'est comme ça que je t'aime".
La scène mémorable du... comment
on appaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiais?
- Du Slip 'N Slide!
- Du Slip 'N Slide.
- Bien oui!
- En bedaine et en
- Bien oui, envoye donc!
Tu règles la "hose", tu pars
l'eau... Je ne me rappelle plus
c'était quoi exactement.
- Tu plogues la "hose"...
- Tu plogues la "hose".
- Ça garroche de l'eau...
- Ça garroche de l'eau
puis tu
- C'est toi qui glisses.
- C'est le fun en criss!
Tu plogues la "hose", ça
garroche de l'eau, puis toi, tu!
C'est un cadeau absolument
inestimable. T'sais, mettons,
comme quand Luc Picard ou
Fred Pellerin m'appellent pour
jouer dans les films, faire
Méo le barbier. Tu te dis :
Ce sont des cadeaux formidables!
Ce n'est pas moi qui est
en Speedo, c'est le ca
Parce que quand je regardais
sa bedaine, c'est pas la mienne,
c'est la sienne.
- Celle du caïd, bien oui.
- Parce que sino
on ne ferait plus rien!
Votre curriculum vitae est
époustouflant! Puis
effectivement, je l'ai
feuilleté,
fasse une sieste après!
(rires)
- T'exagères!
- Bien non! À un moment donné...
- Bien m m m m m m m m m même
temps, c'est la réalité d'ici.
Ici, ça joue, ça a joué 30 fois,
fais-en une autre. Si je vivais
à Paris, à Londres, mes shows
t t t t t t t t t trois ans,
peut-être que j'en ferai pas
trois par année ou etc., mais
ici, on est condamné à l'action.
La réflexion, on peut l'avoir,,e
l'avoir après. On ne l'a pas
beaucoup avant, parce qu'on est
pris dans un espèce de
roulement. Tu as fait un succès!
♪ ♪ ♪
Ma mère est décédée, elle avait
100 ans, puis elle était
curialalalalalalalalalalalité
que je souhaite à tout le monde,
la curiosité. T'sais, je me
disais même... dans le livre,
je le dis à un moment donné.
C'est quoi la qualité principale
d'un acteur? L'appétit!
Veux! Veux, désire, mange tout,
bois tout, baise tout, reçois
tout, vas-y tout, prends tout!
Tu n'as qu'une vie :
vis-la, prends-là! C'est quoi
que j'ai lu hier? C'est Salomé
qui disait... Attends...
La vie ne fais pas de cadeaux.
Si tu la veux, vol
C'est beau, hein? Lou Salomé.
J'ai lu ça hier.
- Merci d'avoir volé un peu
la vie avec nous aujourd'hui,
René Richard Cyr.
- Ça me fait plaisir.
- Merc